it's going to be bigger this ain't
nothing
we've got the ground rumbling now we'll
just wait it's going to really rumble
hundreds of trucks pass through
saskatoon and regina monday before
stopping in balcony for the night
they're convoying from bc to ottawa in
protest of the new vaccine mandate for
truck drivers crossing the border a lot
of people are trying to say that these
types of things are done out of anger
but this is actually being done under
frustration towards the things that the
government is imposing upon canadian
citizens the last few years have been
hard on everybody
we're not getting nowhere
you know this is our freedoms our rights
they've been taken away we want them
back
we want our decision
the convoy was met with a large number
of supporters braving the cold along the
way many of whom say they are fully
vaccinated but are simply against
vaccination mandates they're just going
to be a shift in public opinion in terms
of where we are in the pandora professor
pennycook says coming up on three years
of pandemic life some are willing to
take back control of their own health
risks and this movement is the perfect
platform this
is a
straightforward and convenient way for
people to voice
their frustrations with
uh
well i mean not just the restrictions
but with the pandemic itself
just you know life hasn't gone back to
normal and we you know we got vaccinated
and everything most of us are vaccinated
um we kind of want our life to go back
to normal he also acknowledges that the
protest's messaging could be hijacked if
the convoy turns into multiple protests
at once
people come
no they have some sort of grievances
and the protesters in the outlet for
whatever grievances they happen to have
and so you know their support for the
protest may have nothing to do with what
the organizers are trying to accomplish
or any certain certainly any policy or
any specific policy uh recommendations
or changes ian duffy global news